now given the severity of that
indictment morally of Trump what is your
perspective on someone who votes for
Trump I mean is that there there has to
be I'm guessing some accounting for if
you are so easily able to discern this
reality about Donald Trump how do you
understand and interpret someone who
says despite all of those things I just
heard Sam say I'm gonna go and vote for
the guy well I got I think a lot of
people don't see this about him I mean
that's that's one and maybe a lot of
people don't care about dishonesty to
the degree that I do I find his lying
and its consequences for our politics
you know one of this is probably the
most objectionable thing about him but
so people people don't really care about
that they just they they have a few
memes rattling around their heads like
you know all politicians lie as though
that you know there was some kind of
equivalence between you know catching
catching Obama or Clinton or anyone else
in a lie and what Trump gets up to every
day so and I think there's just the in
part it comes back to where we started
this conversation people are so sick of
the status quo and the falsity of what
they perceive the the quote elites to be
advertising to them that and Hillary
Clinton was you know almost the the
perfect case of somebody who seemed to
lack you know a kind of a genuine set of
ideas I mean ironically Trump in being
the the biggest liar anyone who's ever
seen manages to rebrand his dishonesty
as a kind of authenticity right I mean
he's he's just being himself yes right
he's and he's and he just doesn't give a
[ __ ] about the consequences and that is
so refreshing
that's so refreshing for people they and
so he just steamrolled through
Republican politics with that kind of
superpower where he just was not going
to honor anyone's norms and there are so
many I mean they're the you know there's
different segments of the population who
support him they're people who just want
to see it all burn right so that's kind
of a nihilism that just wanted to roll
the dice with with change so radical and
and
you know non ordinary a nun governor
bowl that they just you know it was just
a they just wanted to throw a a Molotov
cocktail into the center of our politics
to see what would happen but it's not
all that it's people who just cannot
believe how many people are being
accused of being racist or sexist or
Islamophobic and you know where does
this stop right I say some I mean I'm
sort of thinking through these examples
and so one was you mentioned that the
sort of dissatisfaction or being sick
and tired of elites as one reason why
people went to Trump isn't Trump the
epitome of the elite I mean he's the New
York born to a rich dad who gave him a
small loan of a million dollars he is
the so it's a small loan of four hundred
million dollars or it was or even you
know when you talk about like if people
are sick and tired of people being
accused of being racists I don't know
how that gets you to say I would vote
for Hillary other than I don't like
people being accused of racism so I'm
voting for Trump like oh it seems like
only the most lacking in all information
voter might consider such a such a
decision well there are many people who
just lack information right so you know
there are many people who voted for
Trump who assumed that he really was
this brilliant businessman and that his
you know how he seemed to be on the
apprentice you know the year after year
you know the this true captain of
industry was in fact his real bio right
he wasn't just a a sherlock meister you
know Brander of property he didn't build
in many cases and you know just an
actual thief right I mean he just is a
guy who's trailing thousands of lawsuits
you know me just a there's there's
single examples from his biography that
should have been totally disqualifying
for him interesting at Trump University
yes how that was run the fact that he
would pretend to you know he would claim
to give money to to charities
without really giving the money to the
charities and he would show up at the
ribbon-cutting who'd crash a
ribbon-cutting for for PR purposes you
know at a hospital or some other charity
even veterans charities which is sort of
a sacred cow in fact for some of the
electorate he was trying to appeal to
exactly and and and never give a dime
all right so it's just it's some so
people don't have that information and
they're not disposed to seek it out and
they're so but if something truly
perverse happened I mean the the people
just loved to see the reaction he was
getting from the left and from the the
center yeah and from they even from the
never Trump errs on the you know on the
right or the center-right they just
loved the spectacle and he turned the
entire world into a reality TV show
and we're still in it and and people
there was just something it's it was a
kind of perfect storm of of American
failings coming together I mean our our
our kind of bewitchment by media and
fame and the fact that you know that if
you can just get a laugh at a debate you
know you win right if you just get a
laugh at somebody else's expense this is
the nature of our political debates
where you just if you have a line that
doesn't sound pre-written by your staff
and you can manage to deliver it
naturally and you can get people back
footed by it and to get a laugh from the
audience you have won the debate
unrelated to anything else that was sad
about policy
or wasn't said you know and so when you
know Trump it says you know only Rosie
O'Donnell you know off-the-cuff you know
he he wins right and it's that's how we
elect a president in this country it's
madness
but that's that's where we are and until
we can figure out how to break this
spell you know where we'll be vulnerable
to more of this you know I mean one of
the scariest things about Trump is is to
contemplate what an actual evil genius
could do with his skills right I mean
it's like he I mean III view him as a
kind of I've compared him to you know
that the character Chauncey Gardiner in
in the film and book being there you
know where he was just he just happened
to be a kind of imbecile who's whose
limitations showed up as strengths given
the context right now so I just view him
as a kind of evil Chauncey Gardiner but
he's not really an evil genius right
he's not really someone who can hide his
true personality in a calculated way he
just blurts out whatever's on his mind
and in the current environment it
happens to work or at least it works
with 40% of Americans and that's enough